اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركه
احييكم وهذه العربيه 360 حيث الخبر من كل
زواياه ومن جميع جوانب
طالبان تعيد افغانستان لعصرها الاول وترد
على انتقاده ايران بكلمتين اهتموا
بمشاكلكم
داعش يعود من بوابه الرقه وامريكا تستانف
نشاطها العسكري ضد التنظيم في سوريا
من العاصفه التاريخيه تنظر بظواهر مناخيه
حاده
وفي القضايا السياسيه التي شغلت مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي
قضايا تقنيه في الواقع الليله عمليات
تسريح عمال كبرى تطال قطاع التكنولوجيا
والحصيله اكثر من 150,000 فقدوا وظائفا
[موسيقى]
اعاده طالبان الى عهدها القديم واعادت
معها افغانستان الى عقود مضت تحديدا الى
فتره حكمها الاول عام 96
كان هذا المشهد معبرا عن الوضع الذي ينتظر
النساء بعد عوده الحركه الى السلطه من
جديد وكان مشاركه المراه في العمل وحتى
التعلم جريمه اليوم عاد الطالبان لعصر
جديد من التضييق على النساء حينما قررت
على طريقتها اقصاء النساء حتى من دخول
المتنزهات والحدائق العامه وصالات الالعاب
الرياضيه والحمامات العامه تمضي طالبان في
قراراتها متجاهله المجتمع الدولي لا بل
المهاجمه كل من ينتقد قرارها والنتيجه بعد
عام من عودتها للسلطه مئات من الرجال
الافغان ينتظرون في طوابير طويله لتلقي
المساعده الغذائيه من منظمه غير ربحيه في
كابول بعد قرار طالبان منع النساء من
العمل في تلك المنظمه
[موسيقى]
الاستاذه الجامعيه والناشطه الافغانيه
زينب حكيم قالت في تصريح من العربيه
منع الفتيات من التعليم سيكون لها تاثير
مشيرتا الى ضروره اقتران هذه الاذنات
بالضغوط المدنيه من داخل افغانستان
كتظاهرات الاساتذه من الجامعه
هذه الضغوط وهذه يعني الاذانات طبعا لها
تاثير يعني
ننتظر تاثير لهذه لهذه الاذنات ولهذه
الضغوط ولكن اذا يجتمع معها كذلك ضغوط
مدنيه من داخل الافغانستان والنسخ الشعب
الافغاني وخاصه مثلا نحن راينا بان
الاساتذه الاساتذه الاساتذه في الجامعات
استقالوا يعني وكل هذه يعني المظاهرات
التيرادات المدنيه كلها هذه ضغوط طبعا
سيكون لها تاثير
القائم باعمال رئيس بعثه الامم المتحده
الى افغانستان حتى القائمه باعمال وزير
الاقتصاد في حكومه طالبان على الغاء قرار
يحضر عمل موظفات لمنظمات هذه الحكوميه
واضافت البعثه ان ملايين الافغان بحاجه
الى المساعده الانسانيه
في افغانستان تعليم النساء وعملهن ممنوع
بقوه قانون طالبان خطوه جرت على الحركه
انتقادات دوليه واسعه حتى من حكومات تمارس
انواع القمع والتسلط على النساء كالظام
الايراني الجهود الدوليه والمطالب بالغاء
القرار متواصله القائم باعمال رئيس بعثه
الامم المتحده الى افغانستان حتى القائمه
باعمال وزير الاقتصاد في حكومه طالبان على
الغاء خطوه حظر عمل موظفه منظمه غير
الحكوميه بعثه الامم المتحده للمساعده في
افغانستان قالت في بيان ان ملايين الافغان
بحاجه الى المساعده الانسانيه ومن الضروري
تذليل العقبه الموجوده وزاره الاقتصاد في
حكومه طالبان سبق ان حدثت جميع المنظمات
غير الحكوميه المحليه منها والاجنبيه بمنع
موظفيها من العمل حتى اشعار اخر
الاوامر لا تنطبق بشكل مباشر على الامم
المتحده لكن المنظمات غير الحكوميه التي
يشملها القرار تتولى تنفيذ الكثير من
برامج الامم المتحده ما يهدد بازمه اخرى
ستواجه النساء والاسره الافغانيه لتضاف
الى كل الازمات التي يعاني منها الشعب
الافغاني بلال الوجديني العربيه
معنا من كابول طالب الجامعيه الافغانيه
جميله عمر اهلا بك معنا همم جميله في
العربيه 360
اشرحي لنا اولا عن وضعك شخصيه في ما يتعلق
بانتسابك للجامعه قبل القرار وبعده
طالبات تصميم جرافتك دكتور
وكل قريناتك ليس لديكن اي بديل
برمودا
ولا يسمح لنا الذهاب الى الجامعه ولم يبقى
لنا طريق اخر
طيب انت تظهرين معنا على الهواء الان
والقرارات تقول بانه تحريم خروج الفتيات
والنساء الى الحدائق العامه الى المتنزهات
الى الجامعات العمل في المنظمات غير
الحكوميه الى ما هنالك
ما المسموح في تحركاتكم تحديدا اين يمكن
ان تذهب شخصيا
طالبات
الى اي مكان
في المدينه
هل يمكن للفتيات والنساء
يعني تتظاهر بكثره وان تبقى في الشارع اما
ان كل هذه المحاولات تبؤ الفشل حاليا بسبب
يعني تحرك طالبان ضدها
تظاهرات ميكانين
بالقانون
ان كان لطالبان في الداخل او للمجتمع
الدولي
افغانستان البنات لهن حق التعليم في
الاسلام
من قبل طالبه الى اي مدى الرجال في
افغانستان
متعاطفون مع قضيه المراه الافغانيه اليوم
ام ان هناك
تعاطفا من نوع ذكوري ربما له اسبابه
القبليه والاجتماعيه والدينيه الى ما
هنالك معها كذا قرارات
انا كمان
للبنات
لو لم تولد في افغانستان هل كنتي تتمنين
الا تولد افغانستان او ان تكون الان في
خارج افغانستان كي تكمل جامعتك
خذ دراجون
ولكن
لا يمكن الا ان يعمل خيرا لكل الناس على
هذه الكره الارضيه وان يحققوا امانيهم
وزير خارجيات بريطانيا يقول الان ان
طالبان تسعى لاقصاء النساء من المجتمع عبر
عملهن في المنظمات غير الحكوميه
حركه طالبان ردت على جارتها ايران حول
تعليق تعليم المراه في افغانستان اهتم
بمشاكلهم حيث نشر حساب تويتر اتابع لوزاره
الخارجيه طالبان ردا على انتقادات النظام
الايراني حول تعليق تعليم المراه في
افغانستان قالت الخارجيه خارجيه طالبان في
التغريده انه من الافضل لهم في اشاره الى
النظام الايراني اقناع النساء المحتجات في
بلادهم وان لا يحاول باسم التعاطف ان يلفت
عباره عن مشاكلهم الداخليه الى بلدنا وفق
ما جاء في التغريده
اذا ما هو حال حقوق المراه في ايران بعد
مضي نحو مئه وثلاثه ايام على الاحتجاجات
التي انطلقت في سبتمبر الماضي على خلفيه
مقتل مساء النيني بعد اعتقالها في طهران
قال نائب العام الايراني محمد جعفر منتظري
ان الرد النهائي على شكوى عائله امين لم
يعلن حتى الان وجاء في التصريحات التي
نقلها الاعلام الايراني عن النائب العام
للبلاد انا اسره امين يتقدمت بشكوى ضد
المجلس الطبي لكن سبق هو اعلن محام
والدينا ساميني ان اولياء الدم احتجوا على
قرار هيئه الطب الشرعيه امين البالغه من
العمر 22 عاما اعتقلت اثناء زياره مع
اسرتها الى العاصمه الايرانيه طهران من
قبل دوريات شرطه اداب في طهران بحجه
ارتداء حجاب غير مكتمل وبعد اغنائها في
مركز الشرطه نقلت الى المستشفى
ليعلنا بعد ثلاثه ايام عن وفاتها هناك
ولتشعل وفاتها المدن الايرانيه غضبا من
القمع المنهج ضد المراه واليوم افاد موقع
ايران انترنال بان عمال شركه بتروكيماويات
في مدينه عبدان جنوب غرب ايران اضربوا عن
العمل بعد تلقيهم رسائل تهديدا بسبب
مشاركتهم فاحتجاجات امينه منظمه حقوقيه
اعلنت ان الاحتجاجات تسببت في سقوط عشرات
القتل والجرحى في مناطق متفرقه في ايران
منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر وسطهانات للشرطه
بالتعامل بوحشيه مع المحتجين
المتحدث باسم وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
الى الافراج غير المشروط عن جميع من تم
سجنهم في ايران بسبب ممارسه حريتهم بشكل
سلمي بحسب بتعبيره واشاره رئيس في تغريده
على تويتر الى مساندته نسائي ايران بعد
طرد طهران من لجنه المراه في الامم
المتحده في وقت سابق هذا الشهر واضافها
المتحدث هو ان الكفاح من اجل حصولياء
ايران على حقوقهن مستمر واقعوا حقوق
الانسان في ايران ليس افضل حالا من واقع
الاقتصاد وانهيار العمله وتراجع القدره
الشرائيه للمواطنين الذين عن توفير المواد
الاساسيه بسبب الغلاء وارتفاع الاسعار
[موسيقى]
الى سوريا الان حيث افاده المرصد مرصد
السوري لحقوق الانسان بمقتل سته من عناصر
قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وعنصرين من داعش
جراءه
امنيه بينها سجن في شمال سوريا واوضح
المرصاد ان القوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
احبطت هجوما مبارغتا لداعش على مقررات
امنيه بالقرب من سجن الاستخبارات العسكريه
في حي الانتفاضه بالريف الغربي في الرقه
بعد اندلاع اشتباكات عنيفه
تركز القوات الامريكيه في سوريا لا بل
تكثف من عملياتها في الاونه الاخيره ضد
تنظيم داعش بشكل لافتت غارات وعمليات
ميدانيه لا تخلو من المخاطر طبعا وزاره
الدفاع الامريكيه بتنتجون اعلنت انك كسفت
غارتها على تنظيم داعش في سوريا ونفدت
نفذت نتي 10 غاره بالمروحيات وعمليات بريه
لقتل او اعتقال كبار عناصر التنظيف خلال
شهر الحالي فقط تنفذ الجيش الامريكي ما لا
يقل عن 10 عمليات وغارات وقال متحدث باسم
القياد المركزيه الامريكيه ان ذلك شامل
الثلاث عمليات الثلاثاء الماضي مع قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه ادت الى اعتقال سته من
عناصر داعش ادت احدى العمليات الى اعتقال
ما وصفه الجيش الامريكي بانه مسؤول كبير
في داعش يدعى الزبيدي ثماني غلط اخرى من
بينها السبع في وقت سابق هذا الشهر وواحده
اخرى في اوائل اكتوبر قتلت او القت القبض
على عناصر الاخرين من داعش لكن مسؤولين
القياده امتنعوا عن تقديم التفاصيل عن اي
من الغارات الاخرى
[موسيقى]
مسؤولون عسكريون قالوا ان الغارات البريه
والعمليات الاخرى تبقي تنظيم داعش في حاله
التاهب لكنها لا تخلو من المخاطر ففي احدى
الغارات الاخيره كانت القوات الامريكيه
على الارض حوالي 3 ساعات تقريبا واشتبكت
باطلاق نار كثيف مع عناصر
التنظيمتشينو والمتحدث باسم القياده
المركزيه قال ان كل عمليه يتم تخطيط لها
بعنايه وتاخذ في الاعتبار المخاطر عبر
تكثيف العمليات الاستخباراتيه تتم
المداهمات عاده في الليل باستخدام
المروحيات لقوات العمليات الخاصه شملت ست
عمليات في الثامن ديسمبر ادت الى اعتقال
خمسه من عناصر التنظيم فيما سنه غاره اخرى
في الحادي عشر من ديسمبر اصبرت عن مقتل
اثنين من مسؤولين داعش فيما استهدفت غاره
اخرى فالسادس من اكتوبر بالقرب من
القامشلي شمال شرق سوريا مسؤولا في داعش
يعتبر مهربا للاسلحه والمقاتلين يعرفوا
باسم راكان وحيد الشمري وتم التصفيته كانت
القياده المركزيه اعلنت في الثلاثين من
نوفمبر عن مقتل ابو الحسن الهاشمي القريشي
الذي تم تحديده لانه قيادي في التنظيم في
ما وصف مسؤولون امريكيون قتله بانه الضرب
اخرى لداعش ولطالما اعتبرت مثل هذه
الغارات محفوفه بالمخاطب ما وضع قوات
العمليات الخاصه الامريكيه في مواقف يمكن
ان تتعرض فيها لكمين او لمهاجمين بطريقه
اخرى وقد تثير وفاه احد افراد الخدمه
الامريكيه في سوريا تساؤلات من الكونغرس
حول قيمه استهداف عناصر داعش هناك الذين
يتم استبدالهم بسرعه بافراد اخرين من
التنظيم
في سوريا التي تضم ثلاثين مركز احتجاز
يؤذي الالاف من المقاتلين المسجونين اضافه
الى ان المخيمات القريبه تضم نحو 56 الف
شخص معظمه من النساء والاطفال المرتبطين
بالمقاتلين المسجونين وبالتالي ربما تكون
مخيمات قنبله موقوته تحتفظ الولايات
المتحده بحواله 1000 جندي في مواقع مختلفه
داخل سوريا وقال مسؤولون الى الهجمات
الصاروخيه والهجمات الاخرى هي تذكير منتظم
بالاخطار التي تشكلها الجماعه لذلك وجب
تكثيف استهداف وهو ما حصل فعلا
[موسيقى]
من دبي الدكتور سمير التقنيه البحث في
معهد الشرق الاوسط اهلا بك معنا دكتور على
شاشه العربيه مره جديده الى اي مدى اثرت
تجميد السابق الامريكي للعمليات المشتركه
في تلك المناطق السوريه الى اي مدى اثر
ذلك سلبا على يعني عوده داعش بقوه اكبر
التراخي الامريكي في ما يتعلق بالحل مشكله
المعتقلين سواء من عناصر داعش من جهه
واعادتهم الى بلادهم او تسليمهم
للمحاكمه وايضا عائلاتهم هناك تقصير كبير
في سواء من الدول الاوروبيه او الدول
المجاوره فيما يتعلق في هذا الموضوع ولكن
الاهم من ذلك ان التقصير يشمل قضيه اخرى
وهو ان من المعروف انه بقي عدد همم يقدر
بالالاف من عناصر داعش موجوده في المنطقه
المحصوره بين شرق الفرات وبين الانبار في
العراق ولقد قامت هذه القوات ايضا بعمليات
عسكريه ضد الجيش العراقي بالذات وهم في
منطقه تمتد منطقه العمليات من كركوك الى
الحدود السوريه وبالتالي نحن نشاهد صعود
هذه المنطقه في اعتقادي همم هي مرشحه لان
تكون مركز يعني ساحه للصدام او الاشتباكات
اقليميه تتغير الاوضاع في المنطقه كل
عوامل استقرار المتعلقه
بالاستقرار منذ عام
2018 في سوريا تتبدل وبالتالي داعش اصبحت
بندقيه للايجار وهي هل الالتزام الامريكي
يبدو لك جدا وكافيا بما يعطى ويمنح من
معلومات وقدرات وافراد على الارض لمواجهه
ذلك حاليا همم نعم سيدي عمليا اذا كان
المقصود هو ازاله داعش
وتفكيكها حتى العظم كما يقال فان الامر
يتطلب جهودا وتواجدا امريكيا اكبر بكثير
وفي اعتقاده ايضا ان موضوع المعسكرات وعدم
حلل معتقلات وعدم محلي ومشكله كبيره جدا
همم كما تفضلتم في تقريركم هناك لحشرات من
الالاف في هذه المناطق وهؤلاء اصبح لديهم
مجتمعهم اصبح لديهم دعاهم وبالتالي هي
صحيح هم صحيح محاصرون وتحت المراقبه الى
اخره ولكن لا يمضي يوم تحدث حادثه في هذه
المناطق بالتالي نحن هنا كي جمر تحت
التراب الولايات المتحده تحتاج لدور اكبر
بكثير في هذه المنطقه كي تستطيع من تصفيه
داعش كما ان القضيه الرئيسيه هي قضيه
التناقضات بين القوى الموجوده على الارض
الا وهي من جهه تركيا وقد ايران وروسيا
والنظام السوري جميعها تجتمع في هذه
المنطقه وعمليا كلها
تستفيد من كل هذه القوى داعش لانها اصبحت
بندقيه للايجار لم يعد لديها خطه
استراتيجيه متعلقه بتصوراتها والعقائديه
وانما اصبحت هي عباره عن بندقيه للاجر
ولكن نقطه مهمه اثرتها فما تتعلق بالعامه
التركي الكردي اين يمكن ان نضع هذا العامل
في سياق العوامل الاخرى المهمه التي تؤثر
في هذا الموضوع كان من ناحيه العلاقه
التركيه الامريكيه مدى قبول المجتمع
الدولي بعمليه تركيا واسعه في على الحدود
السوريه التركيه اضافه الى وضع القوات
الكرديه ايضا وعلاقتها المتوتره اخيرا في
الولايات المتحده
نعم في اعتقادي بالنهايه لم تستطع من جهه
تركيه ان تقوم بعملها عسكريه واسعه في في
شرق الفرات وبناء المنطقه الحدوديه على
عمق ثلاثين كيلومتر وقد تحتاج لبعض
الترتيبات السياسيه ترضي نفسها بها
وبالمقابل ايضا استطيع ان اقول بان القوى
الاخرى الموجوده على الارض بما فيها
القوات الامريكيه لم تستطيع ان تؤمن حد
ادنى من الاستقرار لهذه المنطقه وفي رايي
الكل لا يريد ان يوظف امكانيات كافيه
للتخلص من داعش من جهه ولكن بالمقابل همم
يقبون هذه ما يمكن ايضا ان نسبها بعمليه
قصه العشق بمعنى ان تبقى هاجعه ولكن الى
متى كل ما نشات فرصه داعش سوف تنتعش من
جديد وتستفيد من ربع السياسي المضطرب جدا
في هذه المنطقه
من دبي دكتور سمير الترقيه الباحث في معهد
الشرق الاوسط شكرا جزيلا على هذه المشاركه
تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 ايضا بعد الفاصل بالمدافع
الثقيله القوات الاوكرانيه تستهدف مواقع
القوات الروسيه في بخمون
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في محمود تتواصل عمليات
القصف المتبادل بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه وتستخدم وحدات الاوكرانيه في
استهدافها مواقع الجيش الروسي مدافع غربيه
من عيار 155 ملي متر غالبيتها امريكيه
وفرنسيه هذا هو تحاول القوات الروسيه منذ
اسابيع سيطره على هذه المدينه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اربطه
اربط
ني
والثانيه بسبب برنامج
سوق 35 في المستقبل القريب التقرير
والاستخباراتيه ذكر ان الصفقه فقط 24
طائره سوء 35 التي تعتبر احدى اخطر خمسه
مقاتلات على مستوى العالم وفق تصنيف مجله
مجله
35 الملقب بملكه
دخلت الخدمه في الجيش الروسي عام 2014
وبلغ عددها في القوات الجوف الفضائيه نحو
مئه مقاتله سو 35 طائره من الجيل الرابع
المعزز تمتلك مواصفات تقاربها من الجيل
الخامس تتميز بقدره فائقه على المناوره
السريعه ومزوده بنظام القياده الرقمي
للمعلوماتيه ويبلغ طولها نحو 22 مترا اما
سرعتها فتصل الى 2400 كم في الساعه على
ارتفاع 11 كلم بالنسبه للمدى فاسو 35 يبلغ
مداها ثلاثه الاف و600 كم وقد يصل اقسم
الى اربعه الاف كيلو متر في حال تم اضافه
خزانات وقود خارجيه المقاتله الروسيه
مزوده باسلحه ذكيه حديثه تطيح لها الرسم
وتدمير عدد من الاهداف الجويه والارضيه في
وقت واحد وبدقه كبيره
[موسيقى]
التقرير واضح ان المعلومات الاستخباراتيه
اشارت الى ان التيارين ايرانيين كانوا
بالفعل يستخدمون الطائرات للتدريب لكن دون
الخوض في التفاصيل واشنطن اشارات الى ان
هناك تعاونا عسكريا متناميا بين ايران
وروسيا خاصه منذ سنه روسيا حربها على
اوكرانيا في فبراير الماضي واثمر هذا
التعاون عن تزويد طهران لموسكو بنحو 1700
الطائره مسيره هجوميه حتى الان تحدثنا
كثيرا عن مسيرات الايرانيه وتخطط لتزويدها
بالثلاث مئه طائره اخرى في المستقبل
القريب وفقا للصحيفه متابعه في هذه
المعلومات تتهم اوكرانيا روسيا حاليا
باستخدام هذه الطائره الايرانيه لضرب
اهداف المدنيه ومنشات لانتاج الطاقه في
اوكرانيا وقد نفذ ايران تزويد موسكو
بالمسيرات قبل ان تؤكد مصادر مطلعه في
نوفمبر الماضي انها زودت روسيا بعدد من
الطائرات المسيره فعلا لكن قبل بدء موسكو
حربها ضد جارتها الغربيه
[موسيقى]
مثل منفذ الهجوم على الاكراد في باريس
امام قاضي تحقيق وفاد مصدر قضائي بانفذه
الابتدائي
مرضيه حيل الاجانب تمهيدا لتوجيهي تهمه
المحتمله اليه وذكر مراسل العربيه
لم يقتل عددا اكبر وليس لانه قتل ذلك
العدد هذا وانطلقت في باريس
دائره العاشره والذي اودى بحياه ثلاثه
اكراد افاد مراسل العربيه بان سلطات
الفرنسيه اغلقت شوارع المحيطه بالتظاهرات
في وسط باريس مضيفا ان نيابه العمل طلبت
حبسه منفذ الهجوم على المركز الكردي باريس
من جانبه دانا المتحدث باسم المجلس
الديمقراطيي الكردي في فرنسا اعمال العنف
التي شهدتها الاحتجاجات منذ يومين مع قوه
الشرطه حيث المحا الى ان تركيا تقف وراء
الامر
رايت المركبه التركيه شخصيا ولدينا صورها
وهي تدخل ساحه الجمهوريه وعليها علامه
ذئاب الرماديه تابعه للحركه القوميه
المتطرفه وهي طريقه استفزازيه اشعلت غضب
الناس الذين تتجمعوا في الساحات حاولنا
التدخل بين المتظاهرين والشرطه ولم ننجح
للاسف مضطرنا الى الغاء التظاهره
معنى من باريس خالد عيسى ممثل الاداره
ذاتيه لشمال وشرق سوريا وممثل الاتحاد
الديمقراطي اهلا بكم معنا استاذ خالد يعني
لا يبدو للبعض ان الاتهامات او سياق
الاتهامات التي تكيلونها لتركيا
تلقى اذان صاغيه همم عند كثيرين بما انه
ليس هناك ادله او معلومات عن علاقه تركيا
بهذا الشخص او عن علاقه تركيا بالاضطرابات
في الداخل رغم ما سمعنا همم يعني الضيف
يتحدث عنه قبل قليل
تحياتي لكم ولي مشاهديكم الكرام قبل عشره
اعوام ايضا عندما قام احد الاشخاص من
اليمين المتطرف التركي المدفوع من قبل
المخابرات التركيه
بقتل 23
كرديه في باريس ايضا كانوا لا يصدقوننا
وبعد ذلك اثبتت كل الدلائل والوثائق
المنشوره حتى من قبل الاتراك انفسهم بعض
الاطراف التركيه التي دخلت في المعارضه
فيما بعد اثبتت بانها كانت
مخططه همم من قبل المخابرات التركيه وتم
تنفيذها من قبل هذا الشخص وايضا حاليا
لدينا قرائن كثيره طبعا همم نحترم
الاجراءات القضائيه والقضاء الفرنسي ونترك
المحققين اللي يقوم باعمالهم ولكن لدينا
قرائن كثيره تدل بان هذا العمل الشنيع
الارهابي ومن فعل مخابرات التركيه وخاصه
مخابرات همم حكومه العداله والتنميه
المتحالفه مع الحركه القوميه العنصريه وما
ذكره
نفسيه وانه متطرف يعني بمعنى كرهه للاجانب
ولو لم يتم تصنيفه يعني ارهابيه الفرنسيه
ولكن لم اين ثبتت اي علاقه له
ايضا في القاتل الاول كانوا يقولون بانه
طبعا مريض وحتى فقد حياته في السجن المرض
وكان يقولون انه مختلف وكان يقولون انه
هناك لا توجد قراءه ولكن كل القران
بالنسبه لهذا الشخص الذي خرج من السجن
وبعد 10 ايام وكيف حصل على السلاح وكيف
اتى واختار همم
مركز همم الكردي همم
الديمقراطيه الكردي باريس وكان رايحينها
يتم اجتماع اللي تنظيم مظاهره سلميه ل همم
لذكرى استشهاد ثلاثه ناشطات وفي الحي هذا
ايضا يوجد همم الكثير من من ابناء
الجاليات تمارس سواء هذه نقطه
عن طبيعه تحركاتكم الان ومطالباتكم من كان
للسلطات الفرنسيه طبيعه التحركاتكم انتم
في الداخل الفرنسي وما هي مطالباتكم
للحكومه الفرنسيه اين اخترت واين نجحت حتى
الان في معالجتها
هذا هو اعتداء على همم الشعب الكردي على
الجاريه الكرديه وامتداده لمعارك اردوغان
همم التي يقودها لصالح الجهاديين وخاصه
داعش في شمال وشرق سوريا وايضا امتدادا
لمعاركه في كردستان العراق
جنياته همم التوسعيه الاستعماريه نرى همم
اعاد احتلال بعض المناطق التي كنا قد
حررناها من داعش مثل العفرين وسليكانيه
الابيض وهمم ايضا حاليا همم
اعاده بناء وهيكليه التنظيمات الجهاديه
ال- ال- الارهابيه هذا العمل هو امتدادا
لذلك نحن ولكن
العمل الذي تسميه بالارهاب من قبل القوات
الكرديه على حدودها
وموجه لفرنسا ايضا لان على الاراضي
الفرنسيه يتم استهداف
المدنيين الذين لم يشكلوا ايه مشكله لاحد
ويمارسوننا نشاطاتهم حسب القوانين
الفرنسيه وهي تستهدف اردوغان ايضا
لاحداثي شرخن في التعاون بين الحكومه
الفرنسيه بين الدوله الفرنسيه
بماذا تطالبون الحكومه الفرنسيه
على عده اصعده واوجه في الفتره الاخيره في
عده مناطق واقع جغرافيه بتوقيت شبه متزامن
كان مع انطلاق التظاهرات في ايران بخلفيه
كرديه
اثناء بشكل اساسي في شمال سوريا في شمال
العراق الان في باريس وفي عده نقاط اخرى
همم بالنسبه
لكل مرتبط يعني
الحل الاساسي هو يجب ايجاد حل للمساله
الكرديه في الشرق الاوسط الاكراد
وقياداتهم يطالبون بحل ديمقراطيه ضمن
اثاره الدول الموجوده لكي يقيموا الانظمه
ديمقراطيه كل المكونات الدوله سواء في
تركيا وفي سوريا وفي العراق ايران ايضا
همم يكون التمثيلهم تمثيل المتناسب مع
وجودهم ويمارس حقوقهم الى جانب المكونات
الاخرى اما بالنسبه للاردن حتى يطالب بعض
الدول التسليم الاشخاص ويقول يعني بمعنى
ما اذا لم تسلمونا نستطيع ان نقوم
بتصفيتهم وكل المخابرات الدول الاوروبيه
على عالم بان هناك قوائم ونحن على علم
ايضا لانه هناك قوائم همم موضوع من قبل
المخابرات التركيه لتصفيه الكثير من
الشخصيات وانا شخصيا على اطلاع على بعض
هذه
قوائم التي تريد تصفيتها بطريقه اخرى
شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ خالد عيسى ممثل اداره
ذاتيه الى شمال وشرق سوريا ومثل الاتحاد
الديمقراطيه من باريس تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
عاصفه تاريخيه التاثير
وبالتت توصف بعاصفه القرن هكذا وصفت ظروف
الشتاء القاسيه التي تشهدها الولايات
المتحده حاليا والتي اودت بحياه عشرات
الاشخاص وحرمت الالاف مئات الالاف من
الكهرباء من المياه في مدن عده العاصفه
القاسيه اثرت على حركه الملاحه وفتحت
مجددا باب النقاش حول الدور التغير
المناخي في حدوث ظواهر المناخيه المتطرفه
هذه وما اكثرها خلال العام 20 22 في بافلو
وهي واحده من اكثر المدن الامريكيه التي
تشهد تساقطا للثلوج يتكاتف السكان للتغلب
على ظروف القاسيه هناك المدينه ترزح تحت
عاصفه عنيفه متراميه الاطراف دمرت غرب
نيويورك وتقطعت السبل بالمئات في سياراتهم
اضافه الى اخرين في منازل مغطاه
بنجرافات طولها سته اقدام متابع
دائره الارصاد الجويه الوطنيه الامريكيه
قالت ان نحو 60 بالمئه من سكان الولايات
المتحده وجهنا من التحذير او التنبيهات من
الطقس الشتوي وانخفضت درجات الحراره بشكل
كبير عن معدل الطبيعي من شرق جبال الروكي
الى جبال
كما انه من المرجح حتى تستمر المشاكل
الطقس لدى المسافرين تم الغاء ما يقارب
1707 رحلات داخليه ودوليه امس وفقا لموقع
التتبع فلايتر وفي حدث غريب تحديدا في
مدينه جاكسون بولايه ميسيسيبي اعلن
مسؤولوا المدينه انه يجب على السكان غلي
مياه الشرب الخاصه بهم بسبب انفجار خطوط
المياه وذلك ايضا بدوره بسبب درجات
الحراره المتجمده
[موسيقى]
اذا من شرقي بالروكي الى جبال الابل الشمس
كان لازم نكتبها بالانجليزي
تاثيرها من منطقه البحيره العظمى بالقرب
من كندا الى غراندي على طول الحدود
في قسوه الاجواء هذه الى التغيير المناخي
متوقعين ان تتصاعد الكوارث الطبيعيه
عالميه ليس العواطف الثلجيه فقط بالمناسبه
الفيضانات الحرائق وعندما السوء درجات
الحراره بدورها ذكرت وكاله اخبار الامم
المتحده في تقرير ان احداث 20 22 اكدت مره
اخرى الحاجه الواضحه لبدل المزيد من الجهد
لخفض انبعاثات غاز الاحتباس الحراري
فسنوات الثمن الماضيه في طريقها لان تكون
اعلى السنوات سخونه في التاريخ ستكون هذه
هي السنه العاشره على التوالي التي تصل
فيها درجات الحراره الى درجه مئويه على
الاقل فوق مستويات ما قبل العصر الصناعي
وتزداد احتماليه اختراق حد درجه ونصف
مئويه الوارد في اتفاق باريس مؤقتا بمرور
الزمن
[موسيقى]
وهذه بعض من الصور التي وصلتنا عن العاصفه
التي تضرب الولايات المتحده حاليا
[موسيقى]
وقف العربيه 360 ايضا تحذيرات من وقود
اقتصاديه عالميه العام المقبل
بعد ايام
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد ذكر تقرير
سنوي للمركز ان حجم الاقتصاد العالمي
تجاوز 100 ريليون دولار للمره الاولى هذا
العام لكن النمو سيتوقف العمل مقبل مع
استمرار صانع سياسه الماليه في معركتهم ضد
معدلات التضخم المرتفعه كان صندوق النقد
الدولي قد حضر في اكتوبر من ان اكثر من
ثلث الاقتصاد العالمي سيواجهم كينا العمل
المقبل وانا هناك فرصه بخمسه 25%
والناتج القومي الاجمالي والعالمي باقل من
نائم بالمئه وهو ما يعني ركودا عالميا
هل انتهى العصر ذهبي لشركات التكنولوجيا
اغلب الشركات التي ازدهرت خلال الجائحه
تواجه اليوم تحديات كبيره بسبب خليط من
العوامل ما دفعها للاستغناء عن عشرات
الالاف من الموظفين في 20 22
اولا من شركه صغيره ومتوسطه ولكن موجه
التسريح الان طالت عمالقه التكنولوجيا مثل
متى وامازون واوبر
سوفت لدرجه انه تم تاسيس موقعا الكتروني
ليا اوفست اوف يرصد كل الوظائف المفقوده
التي تجاوز عددها 150 الف وظيفه هذه السنه
ورغم ان لكل شركه اسبابها الخاصه الى ان
هناك عوامل مشتركه على القطاع اولا العديد
من تلك الشركات عينت الاف الموظفين خلال
الجائحه استجابه لطلب المتزايد على خدمتها
واميله بان يدوم اسلوب المعيشه الرقميه
مات مثلا عينت اكثر من 15 الف موظفا في
اول تسعه شهور من السنه الجايه ولكن قبل
اسابيع اعلن مارك زوربروك مؤسس شركه انه
سيسامح احد 10,000 موظفا اي 13% من القوه
العامله
امازون بدورها اعلنت الاستغناء عن عشره
الاف موظف في اكبر عمليه تسريح في تاريخها
ان تواجهها الواقع فهم واجهوا عده فصول من
تراجع الارادات والكليه تساءل ماذا ستفعل
الشركه لتعامل مع الاداء الصعب والتحديات
والنتائج المخيبه ولكن ايضا ماذا ستفعل
استعدادا لسنه القادمه التي ستكون صعبه
والعديد من الشركات اخذت خطوات للتسريح
منها تويتر
ومجتمع المستثمرين يودوا ان تكون الشركات
اكثر انضباطا وتشوفا
عامل اخر وهو ازمه تكلفه المعيشه وارتفاع
معدل التضخم هذا بدوره ادى الى تراجع
الاعلانات عبر الانترنت والمنصات الرقميه
كما ان بعض تغيرات في قواعد الخصوصيه لدى
شركه مثل ابل ضربت سوق الاعلانات وفي مجال
التكنولوجيا الخدمه الماليه طلقت الشركات
ايضا ضربه من ارتفاع اسعار الفائده
المستثمرون ايضا زاد من ضغطهم على الشركات
لخفض تكاليفها
قامت العديد من هذه الشركات بالاستثمار
للنمو على المدى الطويل ولم تهتم بالربحيه
اعتقد ان هذه الاستراتيجيه انتهى تماما
ويجب على الشركات اعاده ترتيب اولوياتها
والتركيز على المشروعات والمبادرات الاهم
فقط والعمل لنمو اعمالها وتحسين الاداء
الماليه لان المستثمرين لن يصبر 10 سنوات
كي يرون نتيجه الاستثمارات يجب ان يتخذوا
القرارات الصعبه
الى مصر الذي فصل نصف موظفي تويتر هو من
انصار ضروره خفض التكاليف في شركته
الجديده التي تواجه تحديات في زياده
ارباحها واضافه مستخدم جدد كما يرى البعض
ان رواتب ومزايا الموظفين في القطاع
التكنولوجي غير مستدامه واعلى من غيرها من
القطاعات
على المستثمرين في مجال التكنولوجيا
الاجابه تعتمد على حجم وطبيعه الشركه اذا
كان التسريح مجرد خطوه اخرى في طريقه
انهيار الشركه فمثل هذه الاخبار التي تعيد
الثقل المستثمرين ولكن اذا كان الهدف من
التسريح خفض التكليف فهذا قد يكون مرحب به
من قبل المستثمرين لانه قد يؤدي الى تحسن
الربحيه لندن
[موسيقى]
كره اليوم في العربيه 360 للفنان
الافغانيه عبر بطريقته عن قرار منع تعليم
المراه حيث اختار الفنان الافغاني حسن
رضائي صوره رمزيه معبره جدا عن الموضوع
استعمل رساله وزاره التعليم العالي التي
تضمنت قرار منع الاناث من التعليم الجامعي
كغطاء لجسد امراه او ربما قصد به كفنا
للمراه كما ارفق الصوره بالعباره الشهيره
اطلب العلم من المهد الى اللحد
وفي تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 للرئيس
الصيني
في الوقت الذي تواجه فيه الصين تفشي
العدوى بعد التخلي عن القيود الصحيه
تذكرون كل شيء بدا في الصين وقالت شيء
يواجه وضعا جديدا يتطلب مهام جديده وهذا
اول تصريح للرئيس الصيني منذ تخفيف
التدابير الصحيه الصارمه
هل نعود اليها لا احد يعرف فيديو اليوم من
روسيا او اغرب شجره ميلاد حيث نظم نحو 700
سائق في مدينه
احتفالا ليوم الميلاد لتشكيل شجره الميلاد
التي امتدت مئات الامطار
بسياراتهم احتفالا بهذه المناسبه
[موسيقى]
هكذا نصل الى ختام العربيه 360
على اخر اخبار الساعه لديه وارى ان عنوانك
الاساسيين لا يزلان بطبيعه الحال وضع نساء
افغانستان وايران واضافه الى هذين طاهر
سيكون معنا الليله خبير مالي ليخبرنا كيف
علينا ان نتصرف خلال عام 2023 ماليا
بالنظر الى التقارير
المتشائمه بخصوص الركود الاقتصاد المقبل
شكرا
[موسيقى]